well this is awkward
in an interview with the New York Times
a paper Dana Jimmy Carter says the media
has been more brutal on Donald Trump
than any president in recent memory
Carter is 93 so that covers a lot of
ground but don't take his word for it
Harvard no fan of Trump either analyzed
news coverage of his first 100 days and
found that the president received
unsparing coverage without a single
topic where coverage was more good than
bad but you got to give Jimmy credit for
saying what will tick off the strided
hordes in his party in media Carter
nails the loudest critics for
questioning Trump's sanity which would
and will no doubt cause them to question
Carter's sanity too but the side benefit
of being an old fogey you don't care you
can say what you want which usually
means the truth
at 93 it's not like you need anymore
friends or a job recommendation or an
invitation to brian Stelter book party
if it upsets the crybaby news network
that's life the point Carter's making
that whether you like Trump or not it's
impossible for one man to be everything
his haters say he is instead it reflects
the irrational emotion on their side not
actual facts or deeds even Carter admits
Trump's actions may lead to progress on
immigration and he even offered to help
him with North Korea so JC is saying not
what his pals want to hear but what
America should hear that Trump may not
have been your choice for president but
he's your president talk about a
reasonable Democrat he may be the last
one left haha
all right one it's hard to argue with
the progressive icon you must be crushed
crushed I tell you you might not even
want to comment at this point you know
I'm tempted
but I think this is really about Jimmy
Carter seducing Donald Trump oh I think
that Donald Trump is a guy who needs
friends and Jimmy Carter's a guy who
needs a legacy because I think there's
one guy here who first of all let me
just say can you audience believe the
Greg Gutfeld just gave a monologue
praising Jimmy Carter first time ever
all right so that's the point I think I
think the point is that Jimmy Carter
sees himself going back to North Korea
because that's where he went 94 I think
when the yeah nuke deal got negotiated
under President Clinton and of course
that nuke deal did in the hole but he
feels that he can go back in he can play
a role here in which the entire world I
think you might get a Nobel Peace Prize
if he was able to calm down that guy
yeah you know aunt Jessie you know what
else he said no Russian collusion yes we
have to be we have to believe Harvard zu
Obama was a failure
did he basically in those that didn't am
going down baby talking Carter time now
and Harvard said in the first hundred
days worst coverage ever historically
and it was 80% negative if it wasn't for
Fox News would have been even higher at
90 we were the only ones ahead of 50/50
Media Research Center said this summer
president got savaged 91% negative
coverage by the network nightly
newscasts and it's not just the tilts or
the slant
it's the commentary they've called the
president states of what supremacists a
bigot a sexual-assault er a homophobe
you name it they can say it and on the
policy front I can see you know you had
a tough summer with Charlotte or the
failure of Obamacare repeal that
negative coverage is fair but let's say
tax cuts get passed that's a historic
achievement for a Republican president
will the press cover that favorably like
they would maybe if Obamacare was passed
by President Obama Democratic Congress
of course not and that's where the bias
live so I think at this point the
assumption when the president does
anything is he's either evil dumb or
he's lying yeah it's hard to that's the
truth
you can't be all three Kimberly some
people try figure out which one fun for
you so this was basically an audition
you know it was it was like I want to go
like speed dating but for job search
she's like put me in coach North Korea
and so one I concur with your statement
and you concur with your egg and with me
and with Jesse and now with you too I
like it when you're selective and damn
Purina I'm in but I also think it told
us something else about how how the
Democratic Party has moved so far left
Jimmy Carter because he did say that NFL
players should stand he's like Bobby
he's just gonna go ahead and say it so
like Jesse's thinking wait this is the
my kind of Ted MacArthur left and Jimmy
Carter where are we Democrats he's a
waters world guy now that's right ah you
um do you believe he's gonna get it role
in this administration no no and I well
if President Trump could find a way for
him to be constructive I mean perhaps
but I think it is beyond sending Jimmy
Carter to try to work out some sort of
diplomatic deal at this point I mean
Dennis Rodman just today we're reading
the possibility of b-52 bombers to be
ready to go I think I think that like
the 1994 great effort a for effort it
didn't work I think that we think that
things have moved on so much farther
than that you know a lot of the media
attacks on Trump they blame it on the
fact that he like he tweets and stuff
but he has a response to that he says
that if it wasn't for social media you
know he would have no platform I guess I
doubt I'd be here but war for social
media to be honest with you because
there is a fake media that I get treated
very unfairly by the media and I have a
tremendous platform when somebody says
something about me I'm able to go Bing
Bing Bing and I take care of it you know
Kimberly a perfect example of this was
last week with the Iranian story which
was like floating away but the media was
forced to cover it because he tweeted
about it
of course they discover his tweaks but
it's still right he has to actually
interject it if he doesn't tweet they're
not going to cover it so he's part of
that whole process as he says of keeping
the press honest because otherwise
they're not going to give him a fair
shake as to the list of his
accomplishments and the problem is it's
because it doesn't
their narrative you know it's like
trying on the prom dress it whew this is
the wrong size yeah exactly I never had
that problem very progressive prom but
it does lend itself to a volatile
relationship one but it's it's you know
it's something that maybe this is the
new normal as I like to coin yes I did
but you know what was interesting to me
in all this is that when we think about
President Trump and I think that it
contrary to you I think that in fact
he's having a very difficult time as
president United States and I think he's
divided the country I think his poll
numbers suggest that but what was
striking to me and this is what I wanted
to say to Jessie is what I read this
material and it said that trumps garbage
has been pretty negative but it also
said almost half the time all news
coverage in the country is about one man
Donald Trump and secondly most of the
voices who are commenting on Donald
Trump are not wacky lefties me oh there
conserve their republic I'm glad
yourself a wacky laugh that's because
people on the networks will book right
conservative haters of Donna like that
Republicans so their fellow Republicans
for those Network shows on Sunday where
they don't have a lot of respect from
the grassroots and they've always
disliked Trump from the primary that's
why they get a lot of press coverage
because they're the first ones to
criticize the president oh so you think
it's Republicans I think networks book
people they want to hear from and it
happens to be people that hate it's kind
of like you know when a network will
find a Democrat that agrees with you and
people complain about one I'm like wait
this guy he's like bro education reform
he likes capitalism no he's believes a
personal responsibility I mean you could
do worse you know nation great writer
there you go you're so calm Dorian all
right I'm getting sick now you know the
this this article from The Wall Street
Journal
morning landed on my desk landed on my
desk
ie a producer came over and said right
you better talk about this anyway it's
Scott Adams
wrote a piece for Wall Street Journal
called the power of the presidential
tweet and the argument behind this I
think is that he's using humor and humor
is a very important part of persuasive
persuasion and things that are funny are
easier to remember okay so I I and I
totally agree with that but I go back to
that one some of the things that other
people thought were very funny I just
personally didn't think we're funny
that's okay I like corny jokes so that's
that's my thing but like the nickname in
college I didn't think it was funny I
didn't like it I mean I but I heard it I
saw people cracking up they loved it and
actually when he called kim jong hoon
Rocketman I thought that was funny
yeah a little rocket van Lowe oh that he
added a little yeah little Jesse loves
those I do Scott Adams cuz when you when
you are when you label somebody with
that it's hard to unlabelled them so
when you say crooked Hillary it's like
it it took over almost as a jimmy kimmel
maybe he should have tried to be funnier
when he was making his points about the
Obamacare changes there's no Jon Stewart
little Kimmel no we like Jimmy in case I
ever have to sell a book Roger Goodell
to go to Super Bowl parties I mean I'm a
realist you know I think it's actually
you know I was thinking about what Scott
Adam said and I agree about humor I
think it's extremely effective as a tool
of persuasion and in Donald Trump's case
I think if there is one area where I
would say Donald Trump is a genius it is
at this naming of people right but it's
not a nice thing items not saying I
think it's almost like schoolyard
bullying it and it can be diminishing
I'm it's like oh you know you're the
short guy you're the tall guy you're
with like that's think that's what a
mark oh yeah so energy Jeb was
devastating yes it's devastating because
of what graduate
you can't remove it Hilary yeah but I
don't know that I would say oh yes to
any young person that's a good thing to
do boy what a talent I like when he goes
sad everybody like everyone said well
it's not just on Twitter where he's
funny he has these little asides so even
if he's doing a teleprompter speech
there are points where he'll like repeat
something like oh that's really bad
and it's funny you know what before you
go as when I say what struck me about
Jimmy Carter's thing also was the
negative relationship he's had with
Barack Obama
mrs. Carter said Michelle Obama did not
invite her to a meeting of presidential
wives on mental health and she has been
in the forefront of mental health
efforts across this country
what a dog wow that was yeah you just
don't know how relationships work out up
even among allies yes somebody asked him
to say hey do you have President Obama's
email Jimmy Carter's no well President
Obama was famous for not calling any of
the other former presidents for any
advice when he was in office I think
Clinton would call and then Obama
thought he had it all figured out all
right all right you know what get sweet
that I figured out that we have to go to
a break